build by developers as a dream Paradise
For All Mankind Forest City in Malaysia
is the largest overseas development for
China's trouble property giant Country
Garden but more than 7 years after its
launch only 10% of the project has been
completed at its sales Gallery more
people were interested in looking at the
Project's scale model than purchasing a
home aimed at Chinese buyers demand has
been sluggish especially after China
restricted Capital outflows into 2017
now Country Gardens Financial ws and The
Wider problems in the Chinese property
sector have increased concerns about the
future of Forest City built as a joint
venture with a local company developers
are hoping the government's recent
announcement of designating Forest City
as a special Financial Zone will help
draw in investors so we are now
currently uh appointed our Consultants
to really look into what are the uh the
benefit especially on tax out to Le
people from from other part of the world
to come and uh to cherish or to bring
back uh glory to Forest City Forest City
also says it's reviewing its development
plan Forest City was launched in 2016
the government announced tax breaks for
companies foreign investors and declared
this a dutyfree Zone yet those
incentives don't appear to have helped
much in attracting the numbers
developers were initially targeting at
the main retail area many shops remain
shut
groceries and shops there's not many
choices here it's a very small
convenience store so we have to drive
really far out to get some groceries and
stuff the main attraction of Forest City
for many is the low rent even then
Supply outstrips demand for business
owners low foot traffic translates to
slow
business business I would say is better
now because it's cold in China so more
people are here but ordinarily business
isn't that good real estate experts say
the marketing strategy has to change in
order to revive the place any project
where the majority are more than 40%
foreigners it Doom for failure why
simply because they don't come here they
don't occupy here they don't spend money
here so what must be changed in the
future or even from now on is to attract
the local people to come in whether that
will happen is likely to be clouded by
Country Gardens financial problems
Florence Louis Al jazer Forest City in
jeor state
Malaysia make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer